there's been an awakening have you felt
it who are you I know one she's strong
the boss untrained but stronger than she
knows me
something beside me has always been and
I was awake
and I need help
I've seen this roster only once before
but to scare me enough that
it does now
but the past died
kill it
if you have to
the only way to become what you're meant
to be
I eat someone
to show me my place in all this
we are the spark but alike the fire
started
this is not going to go
the way you think
yesterday
your favorite hero from the force
awakens our backers along with a new
member of the team Rose tell me how does
it feel to be a brand-new character in
the Star Wars universe it's awesome I
still don't believe I'm actually doing
it I feel like I've been living in a
dream for the past seven lives every day
you go to set and it's something new and
amazing and it just never gets old what
are the coolest new sets you've been on
honestly every set I'll go on and be
like this one's awesome I'm the next day
I'm like no this one's better you can't
decide what do you think fans will love
about this new movie there's a lot of
new cool creatures there's a lot of
action and I think the story is
something that we haven't seen in the
Star Wars film before that's amazing may
the force be with you
and you can check out Star Wars the last
bed I in theaters December 15th hey
everybody we got some new Star Wars to
break down new character details and
some new creatures that we haven't seen
before
so if you're wondering why they put all
that force awakens footage at the
beginning of it they released this in
China so it's probably just to help
people in that country piece together
the story of kylo Ren ray and Snoke like
you get all that backstory with them
bring her to me and this is obviously
the continuation of that but it's been
two years so I think that's just a
refresh people's minds about the stories
so far but they did work on a whole
bunch of new last Jedi footage into that
including the new space horses that
people have been calling them they
actually do have a real name that I'll
explain in a sec but if you're finding
me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's a
whole bunch of Star Wars coming in the
next couple of weeks as the movie gets
ready to come out but I'll also be able
to post my non-spoilery review next
Tuesday I think I'm seeing the movie
next week so I think the embargo is up
on Tuesday I'll find out more about that
for sure in the next couple of days and
there is new IMAX ticket giveaway stuff
at the end of the video too but starting
with the space horses so obviously this
is all the kanto by its stuff we've seen
a little bit of it in the behind the
scenes before but they explain these new
creatures are just like race horses
because it's a casino planet they have
all forms of sporting and entertainment
that you can gamble on so of course
they'd have horse racing but their
actual name is fattier so you get a
little bit more of the Kanto bye you get
a little bit more of the early space
battle it looks like it's happening over
the original resistance base that
happens relatively early in the film
they explained that after the force
awakens and after the destruction of the
Starkiller base they just go on the full
offensive the first order isn't gonna
waste any time and trying to take down
the resistance we also get a lot more
shots of the assault on crate the salt
planet here you see the trenches you can
just see that they spent a lot more time
polishing the CG since we saw the
earlier trailers but the other new stuff
you see in here with ROS tico the new
character just takes you through a
couple of the difference says that she's
on when she's with the Finn character as
they go to Kanto by to meet the other
new character DJ who's being played by
Benicio del Toro so the director Brian
Johnson explained that even though
there's this vast universe of characters
there's really only three big new
characters in the last Jedi there's
rose Tico who you just saw that little
featurette from there's DJ played by
Benicio del Toro and then there's Laura
Dern's character vice-admiral hold Oh
who's sort of like the second-in-command
to Leia she's somebody that Leia trained
when she was a little girl she was
always like this really weird person but
we can talk about her a little bit more
in another video she just meant to
present another side of the resistance
like Leia is a very Spartan character
but the difference with the whole dough
character is they just wanted to present
somebody that didn't conform to a lot of
the stuff that you've seen before just a
really weird personality who also was
really good at her job the way that Leia
was so without getting into spoilers or
anything like that they said that whole
dough is basically this bag of
eccentricity so you're just gonna see a
lot of weird stuff from her character in
a cool way you get more shots of Finn
and roses are trying to infiltrate the
first order I love that phasma line
they've been putting in the trailers so
good to see you again the that you
see them on here Rian Johnson actually
teased in black and white a couple days
ago I thought about doing a video for
that but the footage here is actually
way better so I figured I'd just include
this but it seems like them after
they've met with the DJ character and
they're trying to infiltrate the first
order so part of their mission is to go
to Kanto by contact him then they need
to infiltrate the first order this seems
like it's happening after that then we
see her in this first order assault the
same way we've seen Finn's character I
don't know if they're in the same ship
it seems like they're in separate ships
it's just hard to see where the edge of
the cockpit is here on the right side
but part of the idea with her character
is is that she starts out of this just
common engineer and she gets swept up in
the action she has a sister who's a
member of Poe dameron's x-wing squadrons
so she really admires her sister and
there's supposed to be some big moments
a big call to action from her I have a
couple of theories but they're kind of
spoilery and they have to do with this
first big attack early in the film so
through these events Finn wakes up they
find out what's going on with Rey and
then they learn what they need to do to
try and help the resistance because
that's all Finn cares about he just
wants to be a part of the resistance and
help everyone out and so does ROS so
that's why they kind of pair off
together but let me know what you think
of all the new footage so far and if
there any special Star Wars bonus videos
that you want me to do just let me know
in the comments but just a reminder that
because Rian Johnson is doing that new
trilogy last Jedi is the best example of
what
that new trilogy is going to look and
feel like even though the characters of
the new trilogy will be completely
different from these characters but just
a reminder of my non-spoilery review is
supposed to post next Tuesday but if
there's an update to that I'll just
announce that the next time I post a
Star Wars video there's a new round of
the IMAX ticket giveaway all you have to
do to enter just be a subscriber and
leave us Star Wars related comments on
the video congratulations to the winner
from my last video pandemonium 101
please private message me so I can get
your contact details you can click here
for that Snoke trailer and you can click
here for my new Hulk Hulk Buster video
from infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight